we're given a differential equation
right over here cosine of Y plus 2 this
whole thing times the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal to 2x and
we're given that for a particular
solution when X is equal to 1 Y of 1 is
equal to 0 and we're asked what is X
when y is equal to PI so the first thing
I like to look at when I see a
differential equation is is it separable
can I get all the Y's and dys on one
side and can I get all the X's and DX's
on the other side and this one seems
like it is if I multiply both sides by
DX where you can view DX as the the X
differential infinitely small change in
X well then you get cosine of Y plus 2
times dy is equal to 2 x times DX so
just like that I've been able to write
it as I multiply both sides of this
times DX but and I was able to separate
the Y's and the dys from the X's and the
D X's and now I can integrate both sides
so if I integrate both sides what am I
going to get so the antiderivative of
cosine of Y with respect to Y with
respect to Y is sine of Y and then the
antiderivative of 2 with respect to Y is
2y and that is going to be equal to well
the antiderivative of 2x with respect to
X is x squared and we can't forget that
we can in we could say a plus a
different constant on either side but it
serves our purpose just to say plus C on
one side and so this is a general
solution to the separable differential
equation and then we can find the
particular one by substituting in when X
is equal to 1 Y is equal to 0 so let's
do that to solve for C so we get or when
Y is equal to 0 X is equal to 1 so sine
of 0 plus 2 times 0 all I did is I
substituted into 0 for y is equal to x
squared
well now X is 1 is equal to 1 squared
plus C well sine of 0 0 2 times 0 is 0
all of that's just going to be 0
so we get 0 is equal to 1 plus c or c is
equal to negative 1 so now we can write
down the particular solution to this
differential equation that meets these
conditions so we get let me write it
over here
sine of y plus 2y is equal to x squared
and our constant is negative 1 so minus
1 and now what is X when y is equal to
PI so sine of PI plus 2 times pi is
equal to x squared minus 1 C sine of pi
is equal to 0 and so we get C we can add
1 to both sides and we get 2 pi plus 1
is equal to x squared or we could say
that X is equal to the plus or minus
square root of 2 pi plus 1 so I would
write the plus or minus square root of 2
pi plus 1 and we're done